this was the size of the smartphone
market before the iPhone came out
this was the size of the market five
years after the iPhone came out please
don't pop
product Market categories tend to
balloon after Apple enters them it
really ballooned but mixed reality
headsets
the first time in eight years Apple's
expected to enter a new product category
with a new AR VR like headset
it's said to look like a pair of ski
goggles and offer immersive and 3D
versions of FaceTime Maps games Fitness
and more it sounds cool but also Niche
at least right now the market is smaller
than any other that Apple's decided to
go into in the last decade iPhone the
iPad Apple watch airpods so I dug up
some data around Apple's other product
entries specifically the iPod and the
Apple watch to see if there's any hints
at whether this headset will blow up or
first
[Music]
the balloons you're about to see are not
blown up to scale the following numbers
were provided by IDC okay let's look at
the iPod comparison first in 2000 the
year before the iPod came out there were
just 3.3 million Global shipments of
compressed audio players
that number doesn't include walkmans and
portable CD players then Steve Jobs
introduced the iPod with iTunes
these are the four choices for portable
music right now boom that's iPod I
haven't had one right here in my pocket
there it is right there
and within four years the market had
ballooned it was eight times bigger
an apple crushed the competition
remember Rio
doubt it the headset Market is similar
in two ways firstly the smaller size in
2022 8.8 million AR and VR headset
shipped with meta's Quest 2 taking the
largest chunk of that market share Quest
2 is lighter faster and has a better
display than the first generation then
there's also the fact that digitizing
music was a nerdy thing before the iPod
it had to rip discs and this thing
didn't exactly scream I'm super cool
that's a lot like how wearing one of
these is today but on the other hand
easily digitizing and listening to music
on the go was a real problem that needed
to be solved the iPod did it while meta
has told us that we all want to live in
the metaverse one day we don't quite
know yet what problem this nerd helmet
solves okay so maybe the headset Market
is more like the smart watch Market in
2014 the year before the Apple watch
went on sale just shy of 7 million smart
watches shipped
five years later the market was more
than 10 times the size and yes same
thing happened with the competition
remember Jawbone or pebble
there was something different about the
growth of the watch Market though it was
slower to balloon than phones tablets
music players or earbuds
but the biggest similarity between the
headset and the Apple watch maybe its
relation to this balloon the smartphone
market
thanks in a large part to the iPhone
Apple has a massive 2 billion install
base that is the number of active Apple
devices so I called up Gene monster a
long time Apple analyst to ask him how
he sees that playing out with the
headset part of that is their ability to
basically create a market because they
have this big active install base it
allows them to integrate a new product
Within products that their existing
users already have I think the balloon
will take more time to inflate than a
typical Apple product But ultimately be
a lot bigger than a typical Apple
product not as big as the iPhone but
this is a big balloon that Apple needs
to start inflating because if they don't
Google and meta and Samsung are going to
find ways to capture that that
opportunity Munster pointed out some
ways the headset Strays from the Apple
Playbook though the initial headset is
expected to be three thousand dollars
and aimed at software developers versus
normal consumers to me the headset
Market goes one of two ways the first is
like the Apple watch the headset gets
cheaper and smaller and apple gives us
all some reason to wear this thing not
only in our windowless basements but
actually out on the streets we need to
understand that this could be better
than our phones or laptops at something
and well the second scenario is
it would certainly be a new one for
Apple world's largest whoopee cushion